president trump calling the proposal
regressive and unscientific but
public opinion appears to be with biden
a new fox news poll showing more than 70
percent of americans
support a requirement to wear a mask
outside the home
jackie heinrich is reporting live from
wilmington delaware for us this morning
jackie good morning
good morning to you sandra good morning
trace well 16 states currently do not
have statewide mass
mandates all of them run by republican
governors and former vice president joe
biden was
talking to them when he called on
governors to enact a nationwide
mask mandate the estimates by the
experts are will save
over 40 000 lives
in the next three months 40 000 lives
that people act responsibly and
it's not about your rights it's about
your responsibilities
as an american
white house reaction was swift president
trump said biden is politicizing the
pandemic and defended his
administration's approach
of urging people to wear masks while
focusing the work of the government on
therapeutics and vaccines but the
president also suggested what biden's
asking
is draconian big government
he wants the president of the united
states with the
mere stroke of a pen to order over 300
million american citizens to wear a mask
for a minimum of three straight months
if the president has the unilateral
power to order every single citizen to
cover their face in
nearly all instances what other powers
does he have
remember back in june biden suggested he
would use
executive power as president to mandate
masks in public but yesterday
he did not say his administration would
enact a federal mandate for masks
or call in the white house to enact one
he notably called on
states to take the lead only kamala
harris discussed what their
administration
would enact talking about testing
tracing and funding a vaccine
the back and forth comes after a new fox
news poll shows a majority of voters
in every party favor requiring masks and
more than
half think the federal government failed
to respond seriously enough
to the pandemic sandra jackie heinrich
thank you